[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum sorry that sounds
strained another week
glad you're here glad you're back what a
what an awesome episode last week really
went all over the place and the numbers
were great and the listeners and the
views on YouTube and I want to say thank
you to everybody who gave it a shot and
listened you know when we get these
certain guests that have such a huge
following well a lot of these people
aren't following me they're not
listening to inside of you but when
they're on here people listen to it and
if they like it and you say hey listen
to maybe another one give us another
shot so you you know that's kind of what
you do but it was great Grant Gustin was
great and you know I love all the
interviews and I did a little interview
with my grandma just she's on FaceTime
and I did it like a week ago and I
recorded it but I didn't put it on that
other episode so I want to share that
with you now okay Blanco how are you how
are you holding up yeah your crappy uh
are you doing anything to amuse yourself
well you could talk to your grandson
constantly all right hang on well don't
make me sound like a dick I've been I've
been we we talk almost every day do we
not yes we do today with the family yeah
of course I will
I wish I can come there and hug you we
could play some what is it called rummy
cube yeah we could do that we could play
Canasta you could teach me how to play
Canasta that's a hard game to learn
though isn't it how old do you think the
oldest item in your freezer is are we
talking like 20th century not that but
you're cooking for yourself you do not
need 18th century well I love you I love
I love singing with you we have to do
our concerts remember we had a good
concert I played an hour for you we play
we sang together
yeah I like that very much
well you make me very happy you do you
really put a smile on my face every day
just you know hearing your voice and
your support you've always been
amazingly supportive I talk about you in
the podcast all the time you're very
unconditional love that's what it is
isn't it all right I love you dearly all
right give me a give me give it you and
Grandpa song even Irv give me a little
for the first verse I'll see you in the
Morning Sun and when the night is
through I'll be looking at the moon but
I'll be see oh that was good
brings a tear to my eye I love you thank
you bye grandma Blanco Blanche from
Florida I love this woman so much of no
idea I love her just a few things I hope
you're dealing with all this stuff and
I'll tell you why I decided to do get
ready for it
a mental health week I've been wanting
to do this and well we're doing it I got
two amazing amazing ladies who you know
work with me let's just say this
wonderful woman sandy
Dana Danielle and Ellen Wasel life coach
Sandy's a DBT a behavioral therapist and
they both do amazing things but I met
them when I was at Prive Swiss this
wonderful place in Connecticut and we'll
get into that on Mental Health Week but
I think it's really important and I just
kept thinking about I'm like you know
how do I help people it's free therapy
you know for for an hour so you want you
want to tune into that and thank you for
supporting the podcast make sure you
subscribe the links are right here see
look at that there's that and the
handles I'll look up see price does that
that's so
cool I really like that you think I'm
looking at it I'm pretending because I
know he's gonna put it in there but
inside of you add inside a pod on
Twitter at inside a podcast on Facebook
and Instagram please subscribe on
YouTube and Spotify or wherever you
listen to it on both and listen and
watch and share and all that stuff
great episode today a returning guest
but a man a marvel marvel man he was in
guardians galaxies know him as Drax tons
of movies
one of the biggest wrestlers in the
world hard at gold is doing a lot of big
movies we talk about so much great stuff
today
he's so insightful and so honest and
like this lovable shy big hunk of love
man he's just did I just say big hunk of
love sorry Dave you're probably gonna
watch this and kick my ass for that but
I love you he also sent me this thing
from my neck he's just so thoughtful
he's just uh the iron neck and I've been
working with that and it's helping me a
lot so why don't we just get right into
it and also Zack Levi inside of you live
podcast as of now we're still a go
that's July 2nd at the north door in
Austin live podcast two shows get your
tickets we'll see what happens but as of
now that show is a go but you know
things are changing so quickly here take
a deep breath let's relax and and let's
get inside dave bautista it's my part of
you
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
yeah can you hear me yeah I turned off
the sounds yeah you aren't good with
this [ __ ] are you you know with all this
stuff happened it's hard not to talk
about it cuz I'm sure people are like oh
I think people are interested in like
going hey what are what are the stars
doing what are the you know what are
people doing and they're interested in
like don't seeing how people get through
it you deal with like you get anxiety is
this making you anxious you know it's
weird and this is a it's it's been a
little rough for me to talk about
because I you know I don't want people
to have the reception that's like a fake
anxiety so if they concern because I'm
really like fortunate right now um with
I feel like I've I've kind of it's
almost like I prepped for this for years
and not intentionally but I'm just
really I'm very fortunate right now I'm
not suffering personally from this but I
am still suffering from like horrible
anxiety and it's just you know some days
I just wake up and I just I don't wanna
get out of bed I don't even want to wake
up but just depressing as hell and I
think like to myself like I'm feeling
like this and I'm fortunate like how are
people who are like suffering who are
losing everything they have and their
you know families are going hungry they
don't even have you know I can't put
food on the table they don't have access
to food or they just don't have they've
run out of money yeah how are they doing
with this so it's like it's it's a tough
thing for me to talk about openly
because I don't feel like I have the
right to do you know the complainer me
but I am yeah it's killing me it hurts
like personally it hurts I'm watching
people like I sent my momma I know this
sounds like like a petty thing but it
just it broke my heart I had to send my
mom out toilet paper
my mom didn't have toilet paper she's
been going to the store and waiting in
line in San Francisco I'd to get toilet
paper and they won't tell her before she
goes in just waiting line to go in they
won't tell her if they have toilet paper
in stock or not they would just have her
wait in line and
she goes in and she doesn't have it so
for weeks or whatever she's been without
toilet paper so I had to ship out to
learn and I just I breaks my heart that
I have to so my mom taught her
everything that seems like it kind of
looked anything no that's not petty at
all it's like I got a 91 year old
grandmother in Fort Lauderdale and yes
she lost my grandfather in November on
Thanksgiving and his birthday was just
April 8th he would have been 94 and you
know first of all I'm grateful that he
lived that long he was my best friend
and you know they were together for 70
[ __ ] how long I mean he's an
exciting 75 76 years they were together
so she doesn't know what it's like to
not be with somebody and now she's alone
so no one can go over there I think my
uncle recently started going over there
he just it wasn't safe he was like I
don't want to take chances so he kind of
sits like 20 feet away doesn't like you
know right and she's all alone honest a
little you know she's got a nice little
place it's fine but she just goes Mikey
I'm so bored she's got that you know
Jewish New York gags I just I just want
to play rummy cube with somebody that's
like this game we play and she misses it
can ask the games and so she's alone and
she's like I'm like can you order some
kite what are you some food can I do
something she cuz I've got so much food
in the freezer I go that food is from
the [ __ ] 70s nobody wants that food
it's fine if you freeze it it's fine you
know it definitely puts things in
perspective when you're thinking about
yourself you wake it look it what you're
going through isn't is important it's
not look I care I'm like you know people
who are homeless
can you imagine things getting worse for
homeless people and it is it's worse for
everybody out there so you definitely
put things in a perspective but it
doesn't mean that you know you don't
have anxiety don't you know it's it's
okay for I mean look I think we're all
we're all freaking out a little bit here
yeah just just so we just sew all the
way around and just not you know I think
that unknown to is scary like not
knowing when things will normalize if
they're gonna normalize how bad were of
shape we're gonna be in after this you
know what and it bring out to be honest
with you it breaks my heart that this
rule for a lot of people this will make
people even more distant like there's
I've never been the most social guy
but there are certain social things that
I really cherish like you know and I
said something I put a little post on my
Instagram last week but like I love
going to the movie theaters it's like
one of my favorite things in the world
to do and I don't want to ever give that
up and I don't want I don't hate to
think that people are not going to do
those things anymore and then theaters
are gonna go out of business I mean it's
like things like that and even is like
baseball games I love you know I look
forward to feeling able to make a
baseball game and Nationals yeah and
that's my team managed just uh it's a
social thing that I enjoy doing like
with my friends and family and I hate to
think that this will change like our way
of life and people won't want to
socialize with each other anymore I
think they will I think they won't man
though I really hope so because there's
and that's coming from a guy who's
really socially uncomfortable but I
don't I don't want people to be further
apart I feel like our country's so
ripped apart already yeah I don't want
it to get to get worse man and there's
always those those simple things that
bring us together no matter where we're
at with politics or whatever but there's
simple things that bring us together as
a community and there's things like
sporting events movies concerts you're
absolutely right so that's you know it's
funny because the whole zoom thing it's
it's tomorrow night I do a I'm doing a
bingo night for my friends so it's like
40 people everybody then moves me ten
bucks the pots like 400 bucks we give
some the charity you know Ronald
McDonald House or food on foot or got to
throw those names out there but you know
and it's like sitting there watching
your friends the Brady Bunch I got this
[ __ ] big bingo machine I bought this
big roll or it was like 400 bucks people
like how old are you I'm like I don't
know I'm um you know so I you know and
it's funny because you don't I'll sit
there and I'll roll the balls and then
sound right and and I'll bit like b3 and
then my friend Tom will go b3 like he's
my backup my side man my sidekick and
people have a blast and just like it's
it takes you wait for an hour and you
know have some laughs but it's it's
weird it's like I just want to like get
my friend Tom a hug I'd love to give you
a hug you know me I'd love to come over
and give all Batista hug and
uncomfortable hug
the man of the few words in many hugs
hugs yeah do you know I read something
on your Instagram it was it was really
cool it was it wasn't long ago I was
like maybe a week ago
it says thinking of better days past and
better days to come the simple things
like a ball game like you just said with
friends family I can proudly say I've
never taken life for granted
grateful for every minute every
experience every opportunity
life's too damn precious and I refuse to
waste it or take it for granted wishing
everyone good health and better days to
come separately in this together which I
thought was really cool and man it's
pretty profound when you say something
like you've never taken life for granted
yeah I think it's just you know it's I
think it's it's because of where I come
from it's I think from seeing death at
an early age like up close and personal
and I think it's uh it's always me just
trying to make the most out of my life
you know kinda defy the odds like you
know I should have been a statistic and
I didn't realize that I was not gonna be
a statistic I didn't make the conscious
effort to say that I'm not going to be a
statistic to I was almost 30 I was
almost 30 I guess I was in my box I was
you know on my block and never I didn't
step foot out of my block I was just a
kid in DC I was working the streets that
you seen it was about when I was 30 when
I said I just can't do this I gotta make
something out of my life and so uh yeah
I stand by I just I love life man and I
just don't take it for granted I don't
take anything I don't think the things
that I've been fortunate to have or
accomplished or opportunities I've just
don't take them for granted I just
really am appreciative guy yeah anybody
knows you will say that you know those
people those those folks that have faced
such adversity when you see it with
stare death in the face you know and
like you know three people died on your
front lawn or something like that you're
a balance are you seen as dark as they
can get in a lot of ways right so you
know there had to be a moment where
you're like anything better than this is
awesome anything every moment that came
to you after those terrible moments were
like oh wow
I did get in a fight today oh I didn't
see someone by today but look I know a
lot of things you know I look at all the
[ __ ] you're doing too and that's got to
be hard it's like you know you got all
these projects and I see in
pre-production and all the
and you don't like stopping you want to
keep moving right you know I started
everything later in life and I am I
always feel like I'm under the time
crunch you I'm under the crunches fires
like can you I'm getting older I'm not
getting a younger so I need I constantly
need to keep working to make things
happen because I I know and I because
I'm a realist I realized that someday
you know the phones that could be
ringing you know people are not gonna be
calling me to do you know jobs and yes I
just don't you know I don't take her for
granted night I want to take advantage
of opportunities I love the word
opportunity opportunity like one of my
favorite works and if I'm given an
opportunity man I'll just run it down
and I just so that yeah certain things
like this is I mean that's what what I
mean when I say that I'm afraid of the
unknown cuz I don't know when this is
all gonna go but you know I don't I want
to know when I'm going back to work you
know I'm losing opportunities that I had
like my film my spy that should have
been released um was not you know
obviously not able to be released in
theaters and I was really proud of it
because one filmed the family film it's
the first film might develop so but they
were sold to Amazon so eventually it
won't be released but I just I wanted it
to have a fighting chance in the
theaters because I was pretty proud of
it yeah yeah I knew you were I knew you
were upset with it and as you should be
it was just it the worst timing ever
supposed to be like released I'm like
the 11th of March or something yeah so
what are you gonna do that's the thing
you kind of go okay this is the
situation you know it's funny as they
sound stupid man but I learned this and
it does work I thought it would never
work but yeah I remember I fired off
some job years ago and I remember just
things along the way it's like oh this
didn't happen or all this and I just go
I start to think immediately what are
you grateful for stop what are you
grateful for let this what are you
grateful for what you got going all
right you got to you got to awesome dogs
all right you got this you got a cool
grandmother's 91 okay you got it and you
just start and that for somehow
psychologically the brain it works if
you just keep telling yourself positive
things do you do that or are you kind of
like far [ __ ] you want to throw somebody
out of it
you know sad like everybody else I mean
I you know I'm human
you know it something doesn't happen the
way I envisioned my head I you know I
get upset but I I am that guy which is
you know boats back to earlier when I
say that I think like I never want to be
I never want to have the truck people
have the perception of me as issue nor
moaning know them come off that trust me
hey dude Maggie and Ollie would you say
yeah they're kind of like a godsend for
this for this [ __ ] going on tell us
about your dogs can you save these guys
right yeah yeah well what I did was I I
kept them together because they're so
they're they're litter mates and so when
they were first brought to the shelter
they immediately split him up and they
were trying to adopt him out and they'd
never been apart in their life so a
local organization found out about it
and they knew that I had room and
experience with pit bulls so they asked
me if I had also them to keep them
together and so that's right dude I
think eventually because they're just
such great dogs somebody probably would
have adopted them it just probably would
have adopted them separately cuz it
being a most people it's hard for them
to take one but little um too big you
know dogs just uh but they are they're a
constant I swear to god I'm relating
them to so this is how I'm you know I've
been hearing from a lot of people that
now they're home with their kids all day
and they're just going nuts and that's
how I am with the dogs like they're
glittery they're driving me nuts on its
most the time it's all it's all great
but there's so hyper in their side they
like the more I'm around the meteor they
are yeah I just start getting very
demanding over my attention over space
it's just I feel like the more and more
elements the morni they become just now
they're whining and they want to you
know if I walk outside they think we're
going for a ride
pralaya but the car scratching at the
car though just for anime know how to
make you feel guilty to they look at you
like I believe you I just wanna I just
took you for a [ __ ] walk like an hour
ago went for like an hour walk what do
you want no just like I'm sitting on
this couch and you're [ __ ] zoom
zoom and [ __ ] man and you're like
alright let's go out let's play Olaf and
it's never enough and it's never enough
food but you know you like daily rituals
so I have a separate building that's my
office and gym and it's a couple miles
from me so that you are usually daily
ritual we jump in the car we go up there
just get him out of the house get me out
there go in the gym there running around
while you're working out yeah they were
in around they have access to a gym
hello Cal aid enabled here they used to
be fine they enjoyed the ride heads out
the window but now they just sit in the
back seat and whine until we get there
so it's just like we can't get there
fast enough I need to teleport them
there so like that I just see you see
hey just knock it off calm down
well that's fine good thing cuz you have
three kids right and and they're all
grown up yeah and so my 12 year old
stuff we've been uh she's not really
yeah yo he's up in Northern Virginia
he's outside if you see when he's now
you know he's he's a gamer so now I'm
just I know this is his excuse to sit on
you know in his little camera chair all
day
are you playing with those do play games
I don't play games I'm just I'm just not
good I don't have the patience I don't
have a focus and I also if I do find a
game that I like I become addicted very
fast and like hours will fly by I will
not eat I will sit on the game and just
yeah just clean clean up kids have died
playing have you heard those things
where people are on that thing so long
like they have these marathons were
there on 24 hours a day I've heard these
weird stories were they just aren't
nourished and they just play games and
they're like drinking like Red Bulls and
they have that they die yeah I believe
it's an addiction is you playing that
right game but just caused you it's
silly Red Dead Redemption cuz it's just
slow enough where I could sort of like
it's because I need slow these fast
games where it's like every you're using
30 buttons forget it you remember when
we just used Frogger man just cross the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jump on the alligator or directions
that's it for directions you don't even
need a button Donkey Kong left oh right
easy yeah that's what I miss man it just
got too complicated life got too
complicated do you think if I did a
national No
phones day people would do it since
there's no way what they owe god no no
and I'm admittedly
I am I'm really bad at this I get so if
I lose my phone or forget my phones from
where I get pure like anxiety attacks
like I'm losing it you realize that's
not good I hate to admit it I hate to
say it out loud but I feel instantly
disconnected or feel like I missed or
something I can't touch I actually I did
lose my phone I was on my bike and I was
rushing to we've done a screening of my
fire now I was on the highway and I was
flying on my bike and my phone just was
flying out and so I didn't have my phone
and I was having so much anxiety about
it
so I went later back to the highway and
I didn't turn my bike off I left it I
left the battery off and I went for an
hour looking for my phone and I found
pieces of it came back my bike my bike
was dead so now I'm up on the highway
with the notation oh oh my god but yeah
I'm so addicted to my phone that's why I
was thinking here's the reality I know
we're all on our phones and you got the
instagrams and the tic TOCs and the
podcast and everything and it's just
like we're constantly on that but what
it does as much as you think it connects
us and I'm dude I'm do I do it - I'm not
[ __ ] preaching it disconnects us so
for sure so you go out to dinner it's
still kind of like oh I just want to say
oh yeah oh yeah it's it is it's like
heroin dude it's [ __ ] here when I
wonder if people could just do it for a
day I mean we were all doing it before
2000 when it's cell phones come out how
was your night it was good I just you
know the phones
you know these cell phones are just you
know they're convenient right I am not
guilty of like I can sit through dinner
without looking at my phone I it I love
if I'm going out to dinner with people I
want to sit and I want to talk with them
and I would eat enjoy the evening I I
stick my nose up at a table full of
people on their phones I also don't like
my best friend you know Jonathan his
kids will not put down their they'll
[ __ ] through every meal all day long on
their phones and it tries to be insane
so and he knows it dries why don't you
know there's a rule that
we do you know with my friends we when
we're having breakfast or something
everybody puts their phone in the middle
and no one touches it the first one he
grabs her home pace for the whole
[ __ ] table just the way it is Hey
look everybody look at that guys we had
a conversation you didn't need your
phone and here's the thing my grandma's
like you didn't hear your phone ring I
never ever have my ringer on or my text
I look I figure I look at my phone
enough that if I look at it 20 minutes
and I get a text I'll respond I don't
need to hear it ringing and doing this
[ __ ] constantly and dinging my friend
Joe I love him Dean it's a notification
from whatever like eight million things
every second it's dinging I'm like how
the [ __ ] are you doing anything with
your life no I don't I don't get any of
those either no my phone's always on
silence I don't get any social media
notifications you know that but yeah I
am totally addicted to my phone but I do
I will sit down sit it down and you know
important times to sit have a
conversation so when you had a dinner
you're gonna you won't use it no no I
may check it a few a few if you gotta
have to go the bathroom I'd look at
myself or if I got really boring if I
was boring you but you know Rosie I know
I am too do you ever do you feel like it
your neck ever hurts from being on your
phone Linda do you like have like I was
watching some highlights of your stuff
and when they announce your name I don't
think I mean in rolls I've seen you
explode with a you know an a a certain
energy like you know as Drax and brings
like that but when I watch you when they
announce Balthus that whatever the when
you came out there do you think that was
the biggest high you've ever had is with
that at those arenas when they announced
you was that the biggest high you ever
had it's a drug and it's sure that's
what I used to when I used to come out
and do my interest tonight I got this
from Shane McMahon you know Shane
McMahon is he's the son of man she's a
wrestler yeah but he used to always say
my coming-out it's like it's like it's
like heroin it's like shoot Garrow and I
to do that yeah but yeah absolutely it's
it's it's the high up performing it's
all that energy from the live audience
of people screaming and cheering oh yeah
it's pure adrenaline pure adrenaline
I also was thinking man you know I was
like I know if it was gonna dream or not
and if I was dreaming about you but if
you ever like I'm sure it's happened but
you're in the ring with someone right
and and by the way I didn't know that
you had the longest reign as world
heavyweight champion for 282 days at WWE
is that real that true yeah yeah with
that particular title though I didn't
know that that's pretty that's awesome
dude that's totally awesome
yeah I had to drop it because I got
injured really bad and I wasn't able to
perform anymore I had to get surgery I'm
and I'm sorry that we've to fake ate the
title oh oh
talk about depression man huh yeah oh
it's uh it's weird it was depressing
because I was under the same mindset
every injury I always throughout my
career until like maybe the last year of
my career I always thought I was one bad
match away from being fired I was always
worried about my job concerned about my
job which is why I was so so driven I
worked so hard because I you know I was
like my last shot this is my last chance
at being a success of something so
making something of my life so I was
always just fear of losing my job do you
think that's how it is with your acting
career now do you feel that same way
you're so driven you want to be so great
is that it maybe it's just part of you I
think it's well I think right now it's
uh
it's you know I'm obsessed with becoming
a better actor like I just obsessed with
acting I just and it's hard for me
because I can't I can't get better if
I'm not working I'm an on the job you
know learning actor if I'm not working
I'm not learning and I'm like I'm so
hungry to learn this craft of acting I'm
obsessed with it and so it's more that
because it's never for me acting has
never really been about uh being famous
or a paycheck it's really just been I
just been obsessed with becoming a
better actor you know there's still a
struggle for me that's funny say about
famiiy said Fame is overwhelming
symptoms I just want to crawl under a
rock and hide yeah do you really feel
like that do you feel like even at
premieres you do you feel is it that
you'd feel like you don't belong is it
feel that huh
what is it yeah I hate it's all the
above I I've always been really socially
awkward um but it's uh I don't know man
it's just it's a little it's a bit
overwhelming for me but just I mean to
be honest with you I live here in Tampa
it's very removed from everything that
should furlough from a spotlight of any
kind and I live such a normal life but
even here I have you know a pretty big
property surrounded by a great big gate
makes me even further removed but you
know I like it I like I like the
solitude which is why I was saying
earlier for it feels like I've always
been prepped for this like I was social
distancing like way before it was
necessary yeah right you know I I was
talking about that dream I had her or
maybe it was a thought or whatever but I
was like I wonder if he ever like maybe
wrestlers in general that yeah I know I
kind of go all over the place but that's
how my mind works but I was thinking he
accidentally hurt someone it was
actually elbow he didn't need to get
that high cuz you're going so fast and
things happen at her you're like [ __ ]
dude I'm 300 pounds or whatever or I
don't know how busy are but I hit him
and I'm like during the mattress
thinking all [ __ ] is he all right is he
that had to hurt oh my god do you ever
get down there go I'm so sorry I'm
[ __ ] sorry you whisper in his ear
dude my bad to hear [ __ ] hit me in
the balls do something what do you mean
what do you do
that's well that's happened to you I you
know I was pretty lucky that way and I
was also it was almost a hindrance early
on my career because I was so afraid of
hurting someone did I appear to be a
non-aggressive which in professional
wrestling just doesn't help your career
you care too much
right but I did I just spit in the I
didn't want to hurt anybody
because you know that's kind of that's
that's part of our job is we have to
protect the people were working with
because they also need to make a living
they need to go out and perform so it's
really a fine line but there were a
couple of times where uh there was a guy
named Randy Orton I wrestled man punch
and I hit him really hard and he sold it
and I knew I hit him really hard and I
was trying to get close to him to
apologize to him so I kept punching him
and then I hit him hard again and I'm
like gun oh my god I'm so sorry no more
I'm trying to apologize the harder I'm
hitting him and he finally just like
smashed me and he goes just get the [ __ ]
away from me oh my god it was there was
another guy there's a guy named Ron
Simmons who I summed in the eye once I
know I felt my thumb like go up in his
eyelid and I thought ordinarily death
feel horrible but at the time I was a
rookie and this guy was a former world
champion who's at respect of everybody
how's the arm man this guy's mom getting
firing this guy's gonna kill me and so I
go backstage night I start to apologize
to him I go around run and I'm so so so
sorry man he goes for what I said I I
thought you in the eye and he goes no no
I just had some sweat man like he just
would not sell it would anyone make me
feel bad he just wouldn't he just like
you know just one of those things just
happens you did one make me feel bad
about her self-conscious about where
your body just let it go so what about
you what about you have you ever been
hit and you're like a [ __ ] yeah
there was a few times there was a couple
times huh yeah and I never really got
pissed about it because
it was just one of those things that was
easier just you know somebody was being
real stiff they work stiff you know
everyone's trying to tell him to lighten
up but it never really I never minded
being physical I there I was that guy
never um a guy named Triple H said to me
early on in my career you said we get
paid a lot of money to be [ __ ] out of
each other
and I was felt like that's a very fair
statement Yeah right so the crowd should
get their money's worth it's not you
know this is the theater of violence
that's the way I always looked at it so
I'd never mind my brother
it looked to fistful rather than looking
to fake yeah so I never really minded
but yeah I've been a push pretty hard
beat up pretty good and cut and you know
it was I don't mind being beaten up I
just you know when a guy injures you
that's something else because I hire
that's happened as well but how so and I
don't you know quick fingers but I've
had guys put me in the hospital and had
surgery at the fault of other people and
I never did you know I rest on them
again I did I did I wrestle him again um
I worked with him again I never took it
personally
I was just something you you just come
back and move on if the company's not
gonna fault them but not gonna blame
them then I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do
it
do you whether some guys you just like
it has to be cuz I've acted with some
guys that done stuff where he like I
just [ __ ] hate that guy
I just don't like that I've got a
[ __ ] dick the guy's just a dick
there's a lot of those guys rushing when
you're working under you know that type
of environment where it's kind of a
totem pole you know um environment it's
changed a lot but when I was breaking in
it was it was very much a total poser
hierarchy and you had to take crap from
[ __ ] doing some guys took advantage
of it and they were bullies because they
could get away with it did you ever get
in a real altercation with a the
wrestler yeah I got in a fight with a
guy named Booker T over something really
elmo's whose it was a personal issue
it was personal issue but it was the
thing that really bothers me about that
altercation as she started to fight with
me when I was injured and I was soon we
got into it anyway but uh I thought
always thought it was really really low
of him to start a fight with me when you
knew I was injured you know even if he
was pissed at me or not you know you
don't think I was you got you just
dealing with an injury right
let's it's like almost like trying to
pick a fight with going on the ice you
know when he's exhausted he's about to
get off the ice he you just got on
you're like let's go you're like dude
I'm [ __ ] exhausted with you [ __ ]
I'm winded I can't [ __ ] fight you
know what I mean it's your inner being
exhausted with not full use of your you
know your limbs it's like that inside of
you is brought to you by better help
online counseling if you're struggling
with all the things you know I do many
of you do many of my guests suffer from
big guests that you think how do they
suffer and they do anxiety depression
LGBT issues family conflicts sleeping
sleeping is a big problem for me now
self-esteem anything connect with your
counselor in a safe and private online
environment anything you share is of
course confidential better help is is so
easy you just simply fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your needs
and get matched an account with a
counselor within 24 hours that's it you
could easily schedule secure video or
phone sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages sounds like
me for sure if any reason you're unhappy
with your counselor you can request a
new one at any time no charge awesome
you can get professional help when you
want wherever you want better help is a
truly affordable option and our
listeners get 10% off your first month
with a discount code inside so when I
get started today go to better help calm
slash inside
that's better help calm slash inside
better heelp dot-com slash inside talked
to a therapist online and get help who's
your who's your favorite wrestler of all
time of all time well when I was younger
it was the wrestler named a warlords he
was my favorite I I love this guy and as
I get older like probably if I had to
pick a guy right now who's who I thought
was like probably the best ever beat be
Triple H I think he's he's probably the
best wrestler
these friends of them you guys talk yeah
yeah all the time
yeah all the time yes he's a good dude
what do you need gonna interfere when
you meet my crew
what's that with Triple H be a good
interview be a great interview
yeah he's interesting as though he's
obsessed with wrestling I don't know you
know how how interesting the interview
would be outside of wrestling because I
don't know if I've ever really heard him
talk about anything other than wrestling
right that could be me pal you know he
loves bodybuilding I know that did i I
don't know if I ever told you but I used
to love that guy it wasn't a wrestler
but never brother love oh yeah
he'd say picture from I think he has
really you know I was thinking I know
why you work because you know you by the
way you just watched certain roles and
you just like when you say you work so
hard you see it like I'm the first thing
I told James and I saw guardians to was
Leticia stole the show by a mile I mean
everybody's great Bautista I couldn't
take my eyes off him it's he's the
funniest [ __ ] thing I've ever seen
like he's so funny
I can't I think I've told you that but I
was just like you're you're so good your
comedic timing and just the way it was
done I'm like I don't know why you
wouldn't work forever you know I mean
you're just a likeable and you're great
do you want to do because you've been
doing a lot of comedy been doing a lot
of comedy do you want to get like I
don't know what I haven't seen the show
see on Apple the the yeah I haven't seen
that it's that dark it seems like it'd
be dark yeah it's a dark very
post-apocalyptic it's very much a
character role for me it's you know my
you know what I really want to do is
just kinda like drama I'd like just just
regular Lois I'm gonna say I want to see
that you know it's like almost like a
character like Rooker didn't Henry porch
of a serial killer something just like
that you I know you could because you
could pull all that [ __ ] from the past
out you have that in you you know what I
mean like those roles for me
hard to get ahold of but I'm constantly
searching for them but yeah I'm limited
sometimes on its it's sometimes it's
really hard to get people to look
outside the box and see someone like
myself in those roles but yeah I'm
always in pursuit you know it's funny
who in Hollywood would have thought Dave
Bautista is gonna be [ __ ] comedic
genius well seriously who's gonna watch
any any agent or you know studio who
watches guardians goes he's hilarious
this guy's got chops so did you think
when you're wrestling and you're
thinking okay I'm gonna try and transit
transition and acting and I remember you
had those conversations and you were
like no I shouldn't leave should I leave
you're across you didn't know or like if
you do this you're gonna ruin your crew
you're never gonna be an actor and all
this [ __ ] that we taught you guys could
listen to that in the first interview
right were you thinking did someone's
gonna hire me in a blockbuster Marvel
movie and I'm gonna be comedic ly gifted
what I'm saying my reasoning for that is
because so Studios it's gonna happen if
they could saw it yeah who would have
imagined that so why can't they imagine
Hugh as like the tough guy the yeah I
know I never know I never would have
thought that in a million years and it's
weird I it's the Royal they're all in
the first and in the first you know the
first one was James Ken rewrote it and
Drax was written very differently than
the second one the second one I think
James kind of tapped into my humor a
little bit on the first one and and
decided that he wanted to put more that
in the second one but in the first film
like the comedic stuff was it was a
challenge for me like I struggled with
it and some of that stuff would they
reshot like nothing goes over my head
because they really wanted to get a
sense of Drax being such a literal
character um but the stuff in the first
film that I looked forward to was like
the germanish stuff like Drax talking
about like it you know his family being
you know murdered boy yeah and like that
stuff like that scene the really uh hard
scene was was cut out it was uh cut out
of the film um because it was it was
just kind of slow and dark but that was
suppose forward - it's funny that the
kind I never would have thought man I
still don't it's hard for me I don't
find myself funny and it's uh so it's
hard for me to you know but I would like
to do you know what I want to do is I
want to do a round come I think I've
talked to you about this I want to do a
rom-com with Christian Shah more than
anything in the world like I'm dying to
do this rom-com with I will get this
done so no I would get this that I love
it it's a few some dude wrestler blah
blah blah she falls in love that you're
not the kind of guy she would ever date
if all these tats what does that mean
you're like oh this one means mom but
this one means [ __ ] mom and late wife
she's like oh my god I would never date
this guy there's something charming and
lovable about you it's kind of like that
rocky relationship with Adrian we really
like you know he it's the only guy in
the world they can get away with they're
at a zoo in the dead of winter and he
goes yeah you know what are you doing
for the next fifty years your life and
she gets why I don't know am i marrying
me too much I mean it's got to do
something like that where you could just
be that charming comedic li but yeah I
could see that dude I could see that we
tossed around a few ideas one of them
was alone along those lines with me
being a pro wrestler which I'm not at
all opposed to whatever you know will be
endearing and make people laugh enough
but I think we would just make the most
unlikely looking couple ever and I love
her and I love working with her she's
actually I think she's not giving nearly
enough credit for how talented she is
man
she's she's amazing and I love working
with her I Lupino set with her she's
just so fun I'm sure hopefully we can
make that happen because I really want
into that well did I hope that I know it
will happen I don't hope it will happen
I know will happen I mean you've done
already where you've come from it
nothing's gonna surprise me if you told
me you're running for president tomorrow
let's not get ruffle your feathers are
these are lastly these are shit-talking
for my patrons it's a [ __ ] talking with
Rosenbaum this is just a couple
questions you don't have to get real
deep but you just add they're gonna ask
you some questions and you just you know
Raj do you have a favorite tattoo
I have like a portrait of my dogs on my
side there's probably my favorite all
right Jason L favorite wrestler to work
with again a bo b hunter D Triple H
Triple H Marc a what was your honest
reaction I don't even know what this
means
blue teesta so I what we did this
pay-per-view of where I wore blue and it
was I never lived it down like people
were so focused that I wore blue for
this paper you're like Mike here Paris
like it was blue and I I was offended
and the reason why I was offended is
because it was a six-man tag match and
we went out and killed ourselves like we
beat the hell out of each other
and we had a hell of a match and we also
was one of those things where it was the
older guys who had been around for a
while trying to really step up but yes
several of these kids like just give him
a rub and bring these kids he even up
they were kind of already over but just
bring them to a different level make
them bigger stars and what people took
away from that match was that I was
wearing blue like that's all the that's
all they focused on people that like
people doing amazing and then but they
were just so you know obsessed with that
I was they were so focused on me why I'm
blue but that was the big deal and they
started 8ee Batista and I thought it was
just so stupid yeah way to go mark a
will he to go would ask me that it's
just done research on I was like yeah
I'm sure that's something to do with
that Drax or something I don't know
little Lisa if you could turn back the
time and talk to your younger self what
would you tell him oh man I uh I would
just you know it's weird because I uh
somebody asked me with that before my
always fears like if I could go back in
and tell my younger self you know this
is gonna happen that's gonna happen then
what I have stopped working as hard when
I've looked at life differently and I
would never have wanted I don't want to
change things like that in my life I'm
you know proud of the way I grew up I'm
proud that I've accomplished what I have
you know coming from nothing so I think
what I would have just said is this is
it you're gonna be okay dude you're not
you're not gonna die yeah
like that there even when I was bouncing
there was nights when I thought I was
gonna walk out the door then the night
and get shot like I didn't think I was
making making it home but guys and in
the 90s in DC people were getting
murdered
how early it was it was crazy
like it was crazy how many people you
were scared we were scared
yeah hell yeah you know I wish it was
worried I mean I was literally Leah like
we were all worried we're getting
threatened nightly and it was such a
violent place at the time it was like a
war zone this crack [ __ ] you know I
always used that term of people you know
it sounds ridiculous crack [ __ ] but it
was decided to crack [ __ ] man more
people are getting killed for the damn
tennis shoes and so that's what it was
like it was like walking out cuz I
wasn't armed not walking out I can't
defend myself but there's people out
here with like guns that are shooting
here for stupid [ __ ] and I was on you
know the nightly basis when I was bound
to get threat and getting paid wobblin
to do that alright I was doing okay you
know I right first started bouncing I
wasn't making much at all but towards
the end of my bouncer out I was doing
okay I was walking home with cash or
pocket every night you know just you're
working with uh you know in bigger
places with the uh you know good
clientele and you're getting tipped out
um so it was okay I don't have that kind
of complain there was just times when I
was just I you know I
boo threw my money I didn't want to
spend it to know what to do with it so
I'm good weak side you know come home
with a pocket full of money bad weeks I
was it was gone that was broke by the
end of the week you know Jesus all right
that's it just I just like to you know
tell my younger self that you're just
you're gonna you're gonna make it out of
this dude make it off this block it
actually that'd be pretty reassuring
back then you know I mean I'm was I
think everybody wishes like I wish
somebody would have told me in high
school just did you're in your hair in
your balls
don't worry there'll be a hair on your
balls your girls will start to like you
you're gonna grow you're gonna do all
these things but just you know maybe
don't let this one go and maybe maybe
not worry so much about that stuff and
maybe deal with all your dysfunction now
something like that all right Lisa Lee
says really quick what industry is more
cutthroat professional wrestling
Hollywood fell professional wrestling by
far yeah I far because it still
contained its so right there in front of
your face
and there's so much young Hollywood you
know it's weird it is it's it's a
political business that took the
political environment it's a
relationship business but there's always
there's so many more avenues but with
wrestling there's really there's one
Avenue you know up until recently you
know now there's another company that
seems to be a lot of guys seem to be
gravitating towards but at that time
when I was there there was only there
was only one place to beat or you
weren't making a living and it was just
like a it was a hundred guys right there
in the locker room with you ready to cut
your throat to put that belt around
their waist and that that's how it was
it was just so right there in front of
your face Jennifer Ann what was your
favorite scene to play an event on
Avengers end game Oh in game well I was
I was hardly in in game I was in it for
I was very briefly you know I was only a
couple scenes it was like an action
scene night and I think it scene with
four Shaw was probably the scene with
Thor I you know I'm not really an action
guy I don't really enjoy doing action
but um yeah and the infinity war was the
invisibility thing was just so it's just
so ridiculous Emily yes have you ever
gotten excited to meet an other actor if
yes who oh god man Russell I did I was
excited to meet Kurt but I was like oh
man that's that's a big question because
there's been there's been quite a few I
mean there's even you know people that I
worked with it I was excited to meet
yeah that's I'm sorry man I wish I had
like a name right even directors man
that's such a the so long question
he didn't workers don't miss like say
again man like stolen was I I took a job
I took this job I wasn't crazy about the
job but I took it because I wanted to
work with Stallone was I sat in that I
said in our first scene together I got
in and sat with Sean I said look man I'm
not gonna be a fanboy today and I said
but you know tomorrow I'm probably gonna
ask you a hundred questions and before
we finish that I think
I had already contradicted myself and I
just want to tell my question yes guys
who me with I do
I think that was Stallone on the last
day I way to know waited we had a good
time we had a good rapport we laughed
together he knew my name you know called
me a dot face cuz I had these cg air
dots in my face on the guardians - and
the last thing I brought my Rambo
lunchbox and I go hey would you sign
this just how old are you I'm like what
is how old do you I'm not gonna I'm 46
like you got a lunchbox you I'm gonna
sign the Rambo lunchbox I'm like yeah
yeah you could sign to my name I don't
want to sell it or anything I love it
Benjamin HR clearly a very disciplined
guy to work with food exercise what are
some of the things you do to stay
discipline you'd have to go on but just
thought what's with a big thing why
should I follow certain rules with my
diet
I'm gluten free I don't eat red meat or
pork and so there's some of the rules
with my diet which actually helps a lot
as far as maintaining my weight um cuz I
can put on weight really easy like I can
be muscle-bound real easy um other than
that I just I don't know I work out
because I have issues
I work out so much to keep myself sane
this is all like a side effect of my
mental issues I look this way for a
reason and I work out because if I don't
work out I'm I'm not in a good mood I'm
stressed possibly violent I'm not the
same you know sinnard person so I need
to it's therapy for me like working out
there is therapeutic for me so I uh I
did those things I work out no matter
what it is just something and how long a
day come on every day it depends you
that were sometimes if I'm working out
like with weights it could be 30 minutes
to an hour if I'm working out have been
doing a lot more chewed itchy lately
because I'm home I could be in there two
three hours I love
you know just get in there and it's such
jiu-jitsu is human chess and learning
human chess is to me is like I can't get
enough of it like I just constantly
what's it for the brain Taylor what's up
good for the mind
Oh incredible it's credible for the mind
there really is yeah I was talking to
the buddy I trained with his name is
Josh Rafferty and he's of a crazy black
belt we're talking about the other day
and it's like when you're joined you
just you all you think about is jujitsu
you just lose you lose sight of
everything else you just so focused so
dialed in so it just really it's again
so therapeutic for me and exhausting as
well last to Jeremy and what things did
you set as goals growing up and how many
stood the test of time I didn't have any
goals growing up and I know it sounds
stupid but like when I was growing up I
wanted to be not dead and not in jail
like those were Michaels I talk about
grateful goes back to that being
grateful right yeah you know I know it
sounds ridiculous with those literally
those were those were Michaels I just
didn't want to be in jail any when we
did Pat II and of everything you look at
your career your life what would you
like to be remitted you like remembered
about you I hope that uh you know what I
would really like to do and I don't I
don't know if I've done it yet but it's
always my goal to like inspire people
especially like poor kids and that's not
yeah hopefully I'll you know I don't get
that project one day that will just
inspire like people like that's what I
want to do and I use that word a lot
because I like to be inspired oh this is
why I love stories I love films on
television because I love inspiring
stories um so hopefully you know I can
you know achieve that goal of just
inspiring
inspiring people mean a lotta Nelson
I'll tell you so maybe it's through my
story of just you know coming from
nothing and and making a conscious
effort is just not waste my life you
know maybe I don't that's exactly I was
gonna say I was gonna say you are you
are just by you telling these stories by
telling where you come from that
inspires people and people look like
this is a guy who could die any night
this guy who saw so much violence
he wasn't going to amount to anything
what is he gonna do with his life and to
be a movie star and I look at you and
it's somebody who inspires me and it's
it's just it's just nice it's it's fun
to be around you I mean you're one of
those guys there might be like hey come
to Disneyland you know you're just a
just feel like a kid like me I think
we're both like that we get we just want
to have fun we're on a set you get
around people who just take things so
seriously and I like to be around people
that don't take things so seriously not
that you don't sometimes you don't
nobody agreed I mean there's there's one
thing you know they're sinking ourselves
seriously in taking yourself way too
seriously yeah nice something should be
like I like filmmaking is fun to me like
I love being there I love doing I love
being a part of the process and some
people to see people you know gets so
demanding and so irritable and so moody
and still [ __ ] about like what and
this is fun I think it should be fun you
know but I when I get mine started
before my I take myself seriously and
I'm my own worst critic so I'm beating
myself up more than anybody but at the
same time I'm enjoying the hell out of
being there become grateful as hell for
being there I'm not gonna [ __ ] at
people for stupid [ __ ] you know yeah do
you uh but I go ahead no no you go I'm
just gonna say I don't do this as much
but are you this hard on yourself when
you look in the mirror in the morning to
go do you look at yourself a go alright
look good
you're are you always like [ __ ] ugly
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this you and this
your traps and you know it's funny when
I had this conversation with myself
recently and because no I never wake up
but I you know I like I also accept my
faults and I just it is kind of here's
what it is yeah but I recently uh
because I've been working out so much
and I did post a picture of myself last
week because I felt like I I don't know
I felt like pretty good about myself but
there's been a couple times recently
where I fell again and I'm kidding cuz
shape I'm gonna take a picture right now
and post it because I feel good about
myself then I'll take a picture and I'll
be like and it doesn't look good
it's not gonna work out harder yeah okay
this has been a treat man I love you
taking the time you're just uh you know
you're just a genuine guy I love talking
to when this is all over you're
definitely getting hugged and I'm gonna
take you up on your offer to come to
Tampa yeah for sure yeah you're always
did you're awesome one of the my
favorite people in the world and also
I'm gonna text you you know I always had
neck issues and you probably the guy to
talk to at that couple of neck surgeries
I know you've had a lot of [ __ ] I want
to talk to you about just exercises I
could do just to take the tightness and
the traps and all that's done cuz I'm
just always tight oh yeah I know you
have some answers yeah I do I know and
like I don't know though you know the
origins of your issues but we'll talk
about it I have I have a piece of either
a machine that I travel with because of
my neck and I swear by it is that the
thing where you lie down you pump it up
no that's a cow what is that called um
that's a traction machine right right
this is the it's something that's
preventative maintenance it's like an
exercise machine it's called pronet and
what it does is just just helps you
exercise your neck please send me a link
saying I'll buy it today will and it's
just uh it's as much resistance as you
want the recent resistance is through a
bungee cord so it's like a nice light
resistance or you can make it tougher if
you want but it really is to just really
exercise those muscles in your neck I
love it I love you and this has been
awesome I can't what's next when this is
all over I mean you did an episode of I
haven't seen it when could I see what we
do in the shadows it was a great movie
and our you know and I want to see so
you appeared on that show yeah I did a
show last uh last year
I'm sorry their first season I was uh
did a guest spot and they wanted me to
come back and do a reoccurring role but
I just wasn't available which killed me
because I look I for one I love the show
I'm a huge fan the show but I also love
Tiger it's just see Jeana - it's such an
interesting guy but I wanted to work
with him again but yeah it's it's out
there I also did a really a really cool
episode of a show called room 104 that
eventually will come out I'm really
excited about because it's a different
type of role for me um and then I got a
cookie I'm still on scene so I'll go
back and finish that we're right into
like Episode two or three
see on Apple and then you got guardians
galaxy in pre-production so that's gonna
happen eventually army the dad dude
what's that about is that zombie [ __ ]
this gets great so pleased a little I've
seen a little bit of it um have you
watched the Kingdom on freakin Netflix
Oh
the South Korean zombie [ __ ] show
Bautista watch it you'll go okay Rosie
what the hell no episode three and on
you're gonna [ __ ] your pants Oh watch it
I'm really bad about like I've just been
so disconnected to the last few years I
think it's just because I've been so
focused on work and also I have to say
that uh I'm really enjoying enjoying the
[ __ ] out of working with Jason Momoa
what a guy what a nice guy yeah we've
been having a lot of fun a lot of fun
it's just like a big kid man I really
love that guy every time I see no
pretensions I'm totally so we have that
in common and the whole motorcycle thing
yeah oh yeah we're yeah we're I think
we're cut from the same cloth I love it
I won't keep you any longer this has
been fantastic and I love you Ann I'm
gonna text you later more thank you for
doing later allowed to be inside of you
my friend again yeah you're always
welcome to get all up inside of me man I
love it alright take care of it I love
that man I love Dave Bautista I just I
have when you listen to him how could
you not love this guy great interview
just so open and we need that a good
friend of mine he's become a good friend
of mine and you know how we met which we
talked about I think in the first time
he came in but you know he was on
Smallville but I didn't get to work with
him years ago
and then I was at a convention signing
autographs and somebody said hey Michael
um de Batista would like to say goodbye
to you before you leave because he heard
that on the announcement that you're
leaving Michael Rosenbaum was leaving IO
I think I think maybe he means like
Michael Rooker cuz they worked with
Bautista de Botti someone's talk to me
so I went up to his this table is like
hey man I just uh I just wanted to say
hello I heard your name and I just want
to say hi and I'm like oh my gosh who
does that nobody nobody does that Dave
Bautista does and from there I just like
I just of course Mike and I we should
talk there's something to get you on my
podcast and he did it and he's uh so
enough about him he's a Jim let's do a
we're gonna read some fan mail some
really cool letters that came in first
why don't I an announce the patrons but
I want to read this this is this really
cool thing this expressive art therapist
comer she she found this and I remember
she read it to me and last year when I
went to that place to kind of get my
[ __ ] together but I just thought it was
beautiful and it kind of just made me
think about now and I don't know I'm
just gonna share it with you could fast
forward but I think it's really great
the title is trusting if you read the
front page story of the San Francisco
Chronicle on Thursday December 14th 2005
you would have read about a female
humpback whale who had become entangled
in a spiderweb of crab traps and lines
she was weighed down by hundreds of
pounds of traps that caused her to
struggle to stay afloat she also had
hundreds of yards of line rope wrapped
around her body her tail her torso
aligned tugging in her mouth a fisherman
spotted her just east of the Farallon
Islands outside of the golden gate
radioed in an environmental group for
hell
and within a few hours the rescue team
arrived and determined that she was so
bad off the only way to save her was to
dive in and untangle her which was a
very dangerous proposition one slap at
the tail would kill a rescuer they
worked for hours with curve knives and
eventually they freed her when she was
free the divers say she swam and what
seemed like joyous circles she then came
back to each and every diver one at a
time and nudge them push them gently
around she thanked them some said it was
the most incredibly beautiful experience
of their lives
the guy who cut the rope out of her
mouth says sir I was following him the
whole time and he will never be the same
may you and all those you love be so
blessed and fortunate to be surrounded
by people who will help you get
untangled from the things that are
binding you is it just me or is that
just freaking beautiful I don't want to
tell you booth let's get into the
patrons I want to thank all my patreon
patrons its patreon but my pet how we
say that Wow again incredible I'm doing
these fun things now - if you're not a
patron you know we have a thing called
inside of me pretty much you know I
answer their questions so they get to
ask me questions and I answer them on
obviously I film them I film myself
playing a character and that was fun so
we do a back and forth thing and it was
just I had a really good time a because
I'm quarantine but it's funny I think
and thank you again the top tears all
the tears I just sent the merch boxes
for the top tears and did a bonus f we
did a live YouTube I've done two of them
now or all the Patriots every one of
them get on there and what you know I
play songs and stuff it's like an
Instagram live but private for just just
my patrons so thank you thank you for
sticking around
means so much to me and it surprises me
every day I look at all these people and
they're it's community and a family and
I love them Nancy D Mary bee Leah s
Trisha
Yukiko I yelled that one Yukiko Jill I
Brian H Lauren Jeannie kopi Nico very L
[Music]
Barry I love that you're still around
Angelina G Jerry W Kevin R Emily KB
Robert B bullet X I love you vortex
Jason W Tiana Andrew see Alison L mark a
Jason D Chris Wragge Roxy Sean W Joshua
D D
Emily s see JP rocks raccoons Samantha M
Hamza be hums hums hums all moon's up
Jennifer and Stacey be Stacy's mom has
got it goin on sorry Carly t Vanessa in
the sky Vanessa in the sky ream Jennifer
s Janelle be neil w tabitha to 72
kimberly e melissa see Mike Jake M
Catherine M Jack s Carly s Judith
d Judith d Carly s R Amira Amira Ramirez
Ramirez Ramirez
Chris f7 Chad W top tier patrons holy
crap keeping me afloat I love you guys
here's a fan letter for ya that was
really special so I thought I'd share it
with you I hope I don't know what I'm
yelling again hi Michael from Leanne
just want to shoot you a quick email but
you know how profoundly the podcast has
affected my life I'm a special education
teacher I work with blind and visually
impaired children with the shelter in
place
life has been really crazy and I've been
having anxiety attacks listening to the
podcast has really helped me relate to
other human beings who are going through
the same stuff that I am my sister's a
nurse and she also experiences anxiety
along with depression she has not been
able to work for the past two years due
to this I
turned her onto the podcast and she told
me today that it has been a huge help to
her as well thank you for your kindness
and using the medium to reach out to
people you'll never know how much you
truly help us all I'm attaching a
picture at the bottom so you can put a
face to the name
I'm the blonde on the left mom is in the
middle sisters on the right thank you
thank you and thank you Michael
Rosenbaum you are forever appreciated
and loved Leeanne Pritchett and she's a
little quote from John Fitzgerald
Kennedy one person can make a difference
and find it sound like Forrest Gump I
might even try it
ask not what y'all kontrick and no one
person can make a difference and
everyone should try John Fitzgerald
Kennedy another great episode I hope you
guys enjoyed it as much as I do remember
Mental Health Week is coming I think
it's just really important and these
women these amazing women the therapists
of mine and now friends have said yes to
coming on here and helping all of you
all of us so again please subscribe
share the podcast get people to listen
to it it's up to you I love you all and
thank you for allowing me to be an all
thank you for allowing me to be inside
all of you alright
[Music]